you be banned from rides if you're
bursting at the sides
Universal Studios Hollywood hasn't even
opened for business yet and fans are
already pissed off well at least the
ones who have a waste that measures more
than 40 inches that is or as they call
it at the view petite
[Laughter]
sick people
they are terrible
it seems the Mario Kart ride located in
Super Nintendo World can only
accommodate guests with wastes measuring
40 inches or less well I guess my quads
won't fit
yeah I do a lot of squats
in front of a mirror sometimes over a
mirror but anyway
40 inches
that's more than a meter if you're
foreign and fat
and this isn't going over too well with
those who have trouble fitting into
their triple XL gaming chairs maybe they
should try eating a mushroom instead of
bashing it in with a turtle shell
a fat phone would say
yes how dare you laugh at that you make
me sick
it's causing a big outrage on social
media with several people venting their
frustrations from influencers to podcast
hosts to tick-tockers they're calling
the ride blatantly fat phobic but is it
really well if you're an adult sure the
average woman in U.S has a wasteland of
38.7 inches wow wow the average man 40.2
but the Mario Kart ride is likely for
kids you dumb asses
and if your kid has a waist Beyond 40
inches maybe amusement parks aren't the
best Blaze for him
a better destination might be fat camp
which by Design is fat phobic so stop
complaining a ride that has height and
weight limits is not fat phobic fat
phobic is when you're afraid Michael
Moore is going to sit on you
ever over yeah never yeah terrorists you
know there are rides that you can't uh
participate listen I I stopped giving
the damn boat roller coasters when I was
11. okay so when you when you're six
feet and you're 11 it's just not and
knees and legs listen this is fine
if your butt's too big to get in the
ride do something about it but here's
the cool part there's a reason for that
it's weight displacement yes you get a
lopsided roller coaster
it's half the rides not going home Happy
[Laughter]
so I'm sorry that your little chubby
self with is gonna have to sit there and
complain on Tick Tock let's be honest
are they really going to run down and go
there anyways because they're going to
have to walk over to stand in line
they're gonna have to wait you know and
then they're going to try to squish the
little round mushy bodies in there and
it's not going to fit and
you want to be big
there is side effects yeah one of the
side effects of being fat is you don't
fit yes so
so if you are fat and beautiful and
bragging a docious about it I'm telling
your doctor you can't ask me how big I
am
then own it when your big ass can't fit
in something be like well I'm just too
fat for this ride
cupcakes on me
where's my cart where's my card
you know uh Dana but you know we you and
I have both been uh the victims of
height requirements all over the world
why should there be a with requirement
uh we have height there's width and also
there's girth but that's for the other
story later
when I was a kid in Denver Colorado
there is a place called Elitches and
it's like the Six Flags here it's called
Elitch's I think they call it Six Flags
now and uh every year I would go with
the summer fun day camp and we would
wear white t-shirts with a logo on it
and that meant that you could ride any
ride that you wanted and I you know
wanted to be cool I wanted to fit in and
I would be so stressed for days leading
up to this event because I knew that you
were going to have to pass by the height
chart
and I would try I would like I would
just try so hard to be like oh please
let me on this ride in so many years I
couldn't and I had to stand there and
wait while everybody else got to go
around on the ride
and I don't I didn't feel that sorry for
myself except for now that you're saying
that I must have been like that's like
really deep pain but here's the thing
when I I understood it was physics yeah
it's just it's physics weight
distribution and and until the engineers
can figure out something about that
instead of going to ride Mario Kart just
go have a drink my God that story is not
even in any of your books that should be
in a chapter about something about
overcoming I don't know you'll figure it
out if it makes you feel better I'd have
been standing there with you thank you
in solidarity yeah
foreign
no he'd be saying that because he'd be
the one that'd be stuck with Grandma on
the bus because he wasn't allowed to go
into park because he said some creep and
he had to stay there he got his T-shirt
taken away he was revoked there's
nothing wrong with swimming in a T-shirt
okay have you ever fallen out of a
roller coaster
imagine like you have to hold on to the
bar okay if I had I don't think I'd be
here
I would be in the ground
because I'd be dead
uh all these people complaining about it
I I would love for them to just show me
on their little calendar where they were
planning to go to Mario World and then
now they can't yes I don't think any of
them work they saw it on the internet
and they were like if I wanted to and
did go there I couldn't do it right
that's not enough reason to get mad
there are plenty of things that I see on
the internet that I can't do yeah tell
me about it yeah well some of it's
illegal no for me like like a push-up
yeah or like growing your own hair
yourself yes
wow yours were clean
yeah Joe you're going to me Alaska's the
last block aren't you
[Laughter]
because we don't have you figured out
the person who goes first the last time
is Last the next time haven't you
figured that out yet I should have known
that Greg I'll tell you what Phil this
story hit close to home for me because I
am right on the cause and it made me
realize I should eat more pasta because
some discrimination is good yeah if it
gets you out of going on the lame rides
with your cousins
you really hate your cousins I do no I'm
just teasing they're adorable
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else